I was elated you know to get back home
to my family for no more than anything
but to be home to have an opportunity to
make change I see my kids go see my
fiance at the time it really gave me an
opportunity to started to dream and
believe again now out of federal prison
and cancers michael vick is coming here
to his home in Hampton Virginia where
he'll trying to pick up the pieces and
rebuild his life really no way to stand
say while I was incarcerated you know
the most that you can do was you know
push-ups sit-ups and dips I walked the
track every day that makes sometimes
five times a day
I remember one Saturday I think it was a
Saturday with my financial guy call and
he's like hey what are you talking
somebody it was like talk to him he's
like yeah you're like this man you know
you talk to him enough he needs your
help and I'm like all right well Lizzie
then I heard him in the background
and I'm like seven you started talking
what's your goals what do you want to do
and he's like I got to get back in I
said you want to get back in or do you
want to get back in and take over and he
told me he said five I want to take the
game back over so well how about this
and I shot shot it shot a shot a bull in
the air you know it I said uh what if I
talk to Andy about bringing you back
again getting back on your feet
learning the game and how to be a
professional and then see what happened
he stopped and he's like you would do
that I said why not I take care of my
brother and he's like I would love that
I talked to Andy if Andy had that same
reaction and he said are you serious and
I was like yeah I say it's like my
little brother I said I think it would
be good for him but I think it will also
be good for our team I want to send a
special thanks to Donovan McNabb he's a
great friend and for reaching out to
Andy and just you know giving up giving
Andy at the time to think about the
decision that he could be made and
bringing me in Donovan played a part in
bringing me in I think Andy you know
really felt like at some point I could
help the football team they gave me some
time to get myself in some type shape
I've talked to Bill Polian I've talked
to so many other guys that are like look
nobody in this league I guarantee would
do that what you did enough to open up
to get him
here at the same position to be played
and I'm like I don't look at it as a
threat I look at as a bonus for him and
for us
Marty morning we're good night you know
after heavy practice stayed out the
extra 45 minutes and I was running he
would take me through you know cone
drills and drop backs and I just
remember being exhausted and you know
Donovan would sit out there and watch I
remember we were working out and I'm
like man you got a birch s like like you
struggling over here your eyes he's like
man I am gonna work out like this I
don't like believe me you'll get a pay
off the end of the day I was drained but
at the same time you know because Reid
told me that you know the hard work will
pay off at some point and I didn't know
that in 2010 I will get that opportunity
and a chance to play for the
Philadelphia Eagles you know as a four
time started
so come back and ultimately win come
back clarity and really give back to the
apex of my game really showed that at
the age of thirty that I still had the
god-given gifts to play good football so
to be consistent and to lead a team to
the playoffs I had got traded to the
[ __ ] we played a Monday night the
funny thing was going into that game I
talked to a cover player then they told
me what the first players will be I
thought so jim has you are deep as a
coordinator they're going deep to the
show so whatever you got to do is make
sure we play deep doesn't go lovely to
do so ball goes up I'm live in Tucson
and I looked at the offer I'm like how
stupid can we be after I just told you
what the play was gonna be and he lit it
up torch this I mean it was embarrassing
me what he did and was the best ever
that I saw had been around it's just
kind of throughout the NFL that element
of that lettuce is that element of
running and throwing and making people
miss when defensive players are bigger
and faster and stronger than ever you
have to have a Michael Vick component so
now you know you see more athletic
quarterbacks in the evolution of the
position of quarterback of how to play
the game the guys have a chapter in that
book historical time sex I have one on
the half elders that you know I won't
say you know I'm a cool foot you know
the quarterbacks to dare to run because
it was running before me you know I did
it on such a different level I think
there were a lot of general managers who
you know kind of said I want to try that
type of guy you know I want to try that
type of quarterback in you know let's
transcended over the years you know
you've seen a lot of guys who don't play
like me they play like themselves but
it's just you know my style of play I
didn't invent the way I play football I
just did it a little faster than most
and the game will continue to evolve
it'll continue to get better and you
know you see more guys doing it on a
high level in the future
I appreciate the moment to talk about
the very important bill House bill 1516
which allows police officers to rescue
pets and left their heart cause I know
that I'm unlikely advocate I was part of
the problem when I was at my lowest I
made the decision to make change and I
stand by that now that I could reach
people that activists can't reach I
appreciate that
I think the off-the-field advocacies is
something that it's personal you target
something specifically that you know and
that inspires you and that you want to
see dramatic change in and you know I
told myself that I wanted to be an
instrument of change
he's an agent of change you know
post-incarceration he's glad to be here
on Capitol Hill my first ever lobbying
trip to support the end will fight in
spectate respect to the Prohibition Act
I do regret my previous involvement and
dog fighting I'm sorry for what I did
for the animal during my time in prison
I told myself that I wanted to be a part
of the solution and not the problem
I was gratifying for me and no one else
and and I do it for myself and my family
and for not for anybody else's Grad
gratification will fly home every week
every week to go fight dogs for what
reason I don't know to this day you know
some so pointless as a culture we tend
to like to give people second chances if
we think the earlier here you know the
field you're in an off the field you
heard Michael Vick talk he was no longer
the Defiant you know middle finger young
man that he had been there was some
introspection to him there was a sense
of okay I this was wrong here's what I
plan to do to try and make amends if you
let me over years we all mature and
understand a little bit more about life
he learned obviously with the mistake
that he made and sometimes when you make
mistakes it shines light on something
that you should have been a part of I
was made to it but it's no excuse I
should have known better and so it is
the same when you know better you
but use me as an example he deserves a
second chance of course he does
course he does here's the thing what he
did obviously was terrible but he served
his time he served the time that he
deserved when somebody pays their debt
to society as long as they don't make
the same mistake again you have to move
on
and no one knows whether or not he's
sincere he's done and said all the right
things it seems so why would you not
give the person a chance to move forward
I've learned in animal welfare bills
nationwide do not get enough attention
and I'm hoping that this bill gets
enough attention there's no opposition
to this bill I think we just have to
care please consider House bill 1516
together we could be instrumental change
I think the best part for me is you know
just having a chance to to see change
and I think it'll prevent us from doing
certain things and going down a certain
path so I think you know just that
opportunity to you know continue to and
graining and the kids mind that but this
is what you don't do this is what you
can do this is what you're not to do you
know it's pretty prolific and we're all
turned on him but I think it's a great
credit to him then he didn't just bail
he didn't go holed up somewhere and hide
and he confronted his head on if people
are gonna talk about folks reclaiming
themselves and rehabilitating themselves
what better example is there the Michael
Vick in terms of our recent wellness
woods
which I could take back some of the
things that I did what solution is for
me is to help more animals than are
harmed in the past and if I can get 5200
kids or my thousand people to do to help
out with this cause and help animals
then I'm doing my job
tells me that there's great remorse as
great guilt the angel I don't think so
but I think the changes that he seems to
have made looking from the outside in
substantive changes and I think used to
be a part of
you know Sanada sinister acts going on
in this world and this was a situation
that needed attention that may be the
reason I you know I went through what I
went through to help other people did
not go through the situation I went
through we're educated and we know then
I think of the prevent us from doing
certain things and going down a certain
path
you
this madness get everything these things
can be done
seatbelt going off it's always a
pleasure to come back to school see a
lot of old faces excited about they're
always excited to see Frank
he always stretched that characters is
the best perceived by what you do when
people not watching and examples of that
over our lifetime it's what you do when
people not watch it's not what you do
when they watch is easy to put on the
frame
but when the cameras stopped rolling I'm
gonna see a different man